okay so you want to learn more about
artificial intelligence and machine
learning but you don't know where to
start and that's totally understandable
much like the cloud the concept of
artificial intelligence encompasses a
wide range of topics Specialties
Services ethical considerations
programming knowledge and expertise it
can feel like there are a lot of tiny
tiny pieces to a giant puzzle and it can
feel overwhelming to decide where to
start lucky for us Google has a resource
for that with guides concept overviews
podcasts courses interactive content
glossaries videos and so much more all
created by Machine learning experts
across Google and no you don't have to
be an expert or even a software engineer
or data scientist to understand these in
fact there's even a curious cat feature
you can filter by no really there is so
no previous experience is required to
start learning want to start your AI
Learning Journey today check out the
link in our description and make sure to
subscribe for more AI learning resources
on our Channel
[Music]